cientos de manifestantes ucranianos se
manifestaron frente a la sede de la otan
en Bruselas mientras se reunían los
ministros de defensa de la alianza han
prometido seguir apoyando a Ucrania
algunos de ellos planean reforzar las
defensas europeas 14 de los 30 aliados
de La otan junto con Finlandia
desarrollarán lo que llaman la
iniciativa escudo del cielo europeo
esfuerzo encabezado por Alemania con el
objetivo de adquirir conjuntamente
equipos de defensa aérea y misiles
este compromiso es aún más crucial hoy
en día ya que somos testigos de los
despiadados e indiscriminados ataques
con misiles de Rusia en Ucrania que
matan civiles y destruyen
infraestructuras críticas los aliados de
La otan también hablaron de las amenazas
nucleares a medida que aumenta la
preocupación por la insistencia de
Vladimir Putin en que utilizará
cualquier medio necesario para defender
el territorio ruso
no nos dejaremos intimidar cualquier uso
de armas nucleares cambiará
fundamentalmente la naturaleza del
conflicto y tendrá graves consecuencias
Rusia sabe que no se puede ganar con lo
nuclear y que nunca se debe luchar
el Secretario de Defensa de Estados
Unidos Joe Austin dijo que los aliados
se han comprometido a enviar armas tan
rápido como puedan llevar las
físicamente
[Música]
La retórica y responsable y Temerarios
peligrosa y por eso cuando presenciamos
el ruido de sables nucleares no creemos
que sea muy útil y es peligroso la otan
una vez más No supone ninguna amenaza
para Rusia Esta es la guerra que elige
Rusia
el enfrentamiento entre el kremlin y la
alianza de la otan está destinada a
intensificarse sobre todo porque ambas
partes van a realizar ejercicios
nucleares en los próximos días